Mr
snow after everything you've seen out
there in the
world what are the Hunger Games for are
you
[Music]
are I have the pleasure of getting to
sit here with Mr Francis Lawrence the
director of Hunger Games the ballot of
song birds and snakes first off of
seeing it I would love to just kind of
get your thoughts After experiencing it
in T4 uh in our theater here at IMAX HQ
uh yeah it the was a fantastic
experience watching it um and sort of
approving the final IMAX version of b s
birds and snakes it's uh it's actually
you know most of my movies I finish an
IMAX version and it's probably one of my
favorite times to to watch the film
because you know I've spent you know
years making it and sort of living in it
and building it and editing it and I've
seen the movie over and over and over
but when it comes time to sit in the IMX
theater and you know really be truly
immersed in it it's it's always one of
my favorite moments in in the making of
a film fans of both the Hunger Games
franchise and maybe even new fans to the
franchise why should they experience
this film in IMAX well I think you know
the the large format which I'm such a
huge fan of is just the most immersive
way of seeing really any kind of movie
but specifically Hunger Games you know
for me um but what I would also say is
sure it makes it more immersive when
you're in the arena or when you're in
certain sequences and certain
environments and things like that but
what I really love is also just the
detail that you get to see and that you
get to pick up when you're seeing it in
such a large format and not just the
sort of the detail of the environments
but also the detail and the subtleties
of performance you know we have
fantastic actors in this and you know
it's just kind of shame when you hear
people are like looking at these things
on their phones or iPads or computers
and things like that when you can see it
in an environment like this and see
their faces you know that large and
really get every little Nuance of the
performance I think it's just fantastic
well it goes to like the intentionality
behind it right like that's these things
are meant to be experienced in a
communal way with fans that are really
feeding off of that energy exactly I
think you feel that I do want to kind of
dive into uh maybe a little bit of the
legacy of the expanded aspect ratio that
you've worked with calling back to and
we pulled we looked at Reddit we looked
we've seen this a lot of places but
there's a moment in Catching Fire the
elevator the elevator yeah so you have
heard this oh yeah yeah I was I was it's
one that people are in love with to this
day what went behind that decision the
first movie that I did an IMAX version
of was I Am Legend and so we did an IMAX
print of that um in an IMAX version of
it but what it it remained in a two40
aspect ratio so when it came time for
catching fire and we started talking
about doing you know the games or at
least the majority of the games in large
format we started talking about you know
using the IMAX cameras and filming
certain portions in IMAX and certain
portions just spherically that we would
blow up picking and choosing how and
where we would do it and and also it was
you know it was kind of a relatively new
saying that I think Chris Nolan you know
really started to do with his uh Batman
series with the sort of format opening
up and I didn't really want it to be
random and I wanted it to have an
emotional impact and so instead of
finding things before the games or even
moments after the games it felt like the
games were the spot for us to open up
and then honestly it was a very organic
um you know sort of development of how
it was going to open up because
from the book there's a moment where
she's you know down and she Witnesses
the sort of you know the beating of of
sinna and then the elevator starts to go
up and that's the beginning of the games
and it was kind of this perfect
transition from our 240 aspect ratio up
to the you know full IMAX and because
she's Rising you could have the whole
thing opening up so as it's getting
brighter and she's coming out into the
games and into the jungle the whole
thing opens up and you just feel this
whole new sort of experience kind of
right along with with Katniss so you
know moving then along into you know
this movie it was really trying to find
the the moments in the movie and the
environments in the movie that are sort
of deserving of the the aspect ratio
change um and there I will say there are
moments where the aspect ratio opens up
more slowly as opposed to just cutting
to the larger aspect ratio as the
characters are sort of experiencing
environments uh for for the first time I
do want to ask in terms of the expanded
aspect RTI IO just roughly about how
much film duration is opened up into
that aspect ratio I think we have just
over an hour of um our movie is is you
know full IMAX aspect ratio uh which is
you know which is a fair amount I think
when Catching Fire had in the end I
think it was maybe 30 minutes or
something so this has more um of the
IMAX aspect ratio than than even
Catching Fire had wow okay that's
exciting that's really exciting um I
want to kind of pivot a little bit to a
little bit more of your process and in
particular you know you've brought a lot
of big IP to the screen what's kind of
your process because I feel like with
fan bases and especially with popular IP
there's a lot of you know things that
you feel like you need to bring into it
or or you know doing honor to the source
material could you talk about your
thought process when it comes to
Bringing to life kind of beloved IP I
mean I honestly I think it just has it
has to start with me being a fan too
because I feel like if I feel like I'm
part of that Community then I'm just
going to be doing at a service by being
a fan um originally as opposed to
feeling like I'm servicing fans um you
know I Lov this franchise I didn't do
the first film but I came on in the
second one and I had my way of making
the movies and it's different from the
the way the first film was made but I
think that I love what the stories were
about and I loved the spirit and I loved
the characters um and I love the themes
and so I think that I was attracted to
the same elements of these stories that
the fans were and so I was just kind of
naturally going to be sort of serving
the fans yeah well I think from one fan
to another like it comes across you know
like you can really feel when there's a
fan behind it because exactly like
you're saying like it's not hard for you
to find those moments because you are in
those moments with the rest of the
fandom yeah and I I mean I I think one
of the fun things about this movie is
that you know being you know eight about
eight years or so later from you know
when the last mocking J came out you
know had enough time to sort of cleanse
my pallet for a minute get away from the
franchise for a minute because I spent
about four or five years of my life on
it and you know kind of recharge and
then when it came back I think again
it's fun for me to go back in the world
and revisit some of the the characters
the world itself the themes things like
that but also I have the same Nostalgia
for the franchise that the fans do so
when there's opportunities to sort of
hit those little kind of emotional sort
of touch points with the story um that's
just as exciting for me as it is I think
or as I think it will be for the fans
when they see the film that's so cool no
I that's so awesome I um I want to kind
of dive into what you were just talking
about because that's something that you
know we've read from past interviews
with you is that you would be interested
in diving into more aspects of the world
of PanAm are there any stories of you
know individuals that haven't been
explored or institutions that haven't
been explored or maybe not in depth that
interest you as something that you would
be wanting to do at some point I don't
know you know it's it's I got asked a
lot at the end of the mocking J movies
if I would do another one and and for me
it is always whether or not Suzanne
Collins wrote another story you know she
always starts with a a thematic idea so
the stories always have a very strong
thematic Foundation um they're not sort
of telling stories for the sake of
telling stories they're you know having
more in the Hunger Games world there's
really something relevant that she's
writing about and if she were to write
another book that would be fantastic
because I I would know that there was
going to be substance behind it and
there's kind of a reason for it to exist
um and then I'm I'm really into it
what's interesting is that when we
finished the mocking J movies people
thought you know and asked us what we
thought would be an interesting you know
story to tell and Nina Jacobson and I
always said it would be around the dark
days the sort of origin of the of The
Hunger Games that would be really
interesting I know a lot of fans wanted
you know the hch games or the finck
games and things like that but for us
the origin of the games was something
really interesting and that basically
ended up being what you know Suzanne
wrote about so but for me it all serves
with Suzanne she's got to she's got to
come up with the story and write the
book if you could go back and watch any
movie again or for the first time in
IMAX if you could experience anything
theoretically anything I mean geez I
think it would probably be Apocalypse
Now um you know one of my favorite
experiences in in movies was seeing
Apocalypse Now it was a 70 millimeter
remastered print um at the cinama Dome
and I feel like being able to see sort
you know a remastered version in IMAX
would be really fantastic that's a great
that's a really great pick yeah that's
amazing thank you so much for sitting
down with us we are so excited I know
everybody else is excited to see this
movie too and it's really such an honor
right thank
you